non-minimalists
how can we find silence amongst the
noise of daily life
we touched on this a bit but
i wanted to read something real quick so
i was i remember a few months ago when
uh andrew and i were texting
and uh i asked him if he wanted to be on
the podcast when he was out here and i
was thinking what what are we gonna talk
about exactly and then i want to talk
something about silence and i was trying
to think of some of these pithy minimal
maxims and so i i i wrote down
silence is not the absence of sound and
i'm like oh this is good let me google
to make sure this isn't some famous
quote somewhere
and it is and it turns out it's an
anthony de mello quote oh wow and so
i've i tried to find what book it's in
it's in this book here called one minute
wisdom and i i've been reading this for
the last few months now i'll just read a
couple a day but here's the one here
this is uh this is called emptiness it's
like almost like a little poem or a
little meditation
about silence sometimes there would be a
rush of noisy visitors and the silence
of the monastery would be shattered
this would upset the disciples not the
master who seemed just as content with
the noise as with the silence
to his protesting disciples he said one
day
silence is not the absence of sound
but the absence of self
now
andrew you get into these flow states
when you're making music when things are
going really well and you're in your
studio and you look up and oh my god i
can't believe it's already five o'clock
yeah where'd the time go it's a a state
of no time a state of no mind the
thoughts aren't those inside voices
dissipate
right
and
that is a particular kind of silence now
you're creating there's music in the
background but there's an absence of
self
there and i imagine that when some of
your best music is being made it almost
feels as though it's not being made by
you but through you
hmm
that's yeah that's that's accurate um
my dad asked me that too he's like how
do you
my dad's always
so curious about how i create um
he's how do you uh open yourself up to
inspiration are you just sitting there
and you know lightning strikes and
um
yeah i think that that's accurate i mean
it's it's it's not so mystical for me
it's it's
it's um
sometimes it can be as as as much as
easy as just like i don't really feel
like creating today
but i know that if i just make myself
available to it maybe it'll
you know
and sometimes it doesn't sometimes i'll
sit there for three four hours and it's
frustrating nothing good comes out that
i at least i think is good
but just making myself available
for for those moments is where i find
that
uh the most success will come for me and
um that's just a practice that i have to
force myself to do you know make an
appointment with myself
even if i don't feel like i at least sit
there for three four hours and just um
yeah allow inspiration to come up on me
and you just know like it's
it's good or not good or enjoyable not
enjoy whatever you however you want to
quantify it's more of a feeling it's not
a label necessarily yeah i don't know
how to describe that but it's like um
it's a gut instinct yeah that maybe when
i was first making music um i didn't
know if i could trust but you know
having made a lot of music over the past
decade or so
i've started to trust that instinct a
little more there's like i don't know
when the right chord is put together or
the right
melody with the
phrase or something
there's a twinge or like a little
tingle that i can feel you know that
it's like okay
that that one works you know that that's
gonna we're gonna build on that you know
that's a very literal feeling that i
not always feel but um
there's almost like a sigh of relief
there i can actually see it on your face
even you're talking about it's like
oh
yeah like this is actually because
there's all those other times where like
when you're writing you want to put your
head through a wall and like yeah oh
this just isn't working oh yeah but then
when it does it's the
ah yeah it's it's uh
it's refreshing because you know like we
were talking about inside voices one of
the narratives that i will hear in my
head sometimes is like
you know you're not gonna be able to
write any more good songs you've written
them all and uh
or maybe um
i don't really maybe have as much to
pull from and um
we were talking about this the other day
uh about how
um as people began to achieve success
it
usually typically not always but great
art usually comes from struggle of some
kind you know and then you start to
have success and life gets a little bit
more easy and comfortable
and it becomes harder to
find drama and to pull from
and
so yeah one of the narratives that i'm
constantly battling is just like i'm not
gonna be able to write any more good
songs you know so it is it's very
refreshing when you finally
make those breakthroughs yeah yeah you
don't just go downstairs and like start
picking fights with your wife
yelling at people on the street
i need more drama in my life yeah yeah
oh shoot
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free